[Música]
bienvenidos a esta edición especial de
la entrevista en france 24 hoy estamos
con vitali klitschko el alcalde de kiev
y su hermano vladimir
miembro de la defensa territorial
vitaly cuál es la situación en kiev
hemos escuchado que las fuerzas rusas
están muy cerca de la capital donde
usted se encuentra
[Música]
y en este momento la situación en que no
es fácil hay muchas fuerzas rusas
viniendo desde el norte y el este
asiático
y
están a unos 15 ó 20 kilómetros del
centro de que pero nosotros hemos
rodeado con nuestras fuerzas militares
[Música]
los soldados ucranianos están
defendiendo la capital desde hace mucho
tiempo
[Música]
el objetivo de los rusos es la capital
de ucrania y están tratando de rodear
quien para limpiarla para bloquearla
pero nuestros soldados ucranianos han
destruido los planes de los rusos
y estamos muy orgullosos de tener
soldados tan fuertes que comiendo
nuestras casas nuestra ciudad y nuestro
país
y la situación actual en la capital está
bajo control
tenemos electricidad tenemos agua
tenemos calefacción
pero la situación no es fácil porque los
ciudadanos de que ya han pasado dos
semanas bajo tierra
todo el tiempo se escuchan bombardeos y
sirenas en nuestra ciudad eso significa
que todas las personas tienen que estar
en un búnker
[Música]
y las personas no están en pánico pero
siendo en esto están muy nerviosas
muchas gracias por la ayuda militar
gracias a la cruz roja muchas
organizaciones y personas que apoyan a
ucrania y envían productos y
medicamentos de la ciudad
[Música]
en este momento tenemos reservas en
nuestra ciudad
pero la guerra es desastrosa para
nuestro país la logística se interrumpe
la economía no funciona y en este
momento todos los días mueren civiles
niños
mujeres personas mayores y por supuesto
nuestros soldados
y
evidentemente debe haber preocupación
porque la segunda ciudad principal del
país markoff está siendo bombardeada hay
precedentes de lo que hizo rusia en
grozny chechenia en alepo siria le
preocupa que haya un ataque de gran
envergadura para tratar de tomar se
quiere es
real
no son preocupaciones es la realidad y
lo hemos visto y esas imágenes no
mienten la ciudad de kharkiv ha sido
bombardeada y no sólo esa
mariupol también
de
windsor de sus
ambos variados los distritos de la
ciudad
las áreas residenciales de la ciudad
donde no hay infraestructura militar
importante que los rusos deban destruir
simplemente están destruyendo vidas
humanas
matan niños familias y destruyen casas
un chiquillo
esto no tiene nada que ver con la guerra
contra el ejército ucraniano como tratan
de decir los rusos
esto es un asesinato de civiles y deben
detenerse
ha habido bombardeos en todo el país
incluso el este del país ha sido atacado
hasta mil cohetes rusos han caído en los
últimos días sobre el suelo ucraniano
y green
el enorme ejército ruso está tratando de
rodear la capital de ucrania la ciudad
de kiev
mientras hablamos hay combates alrededor
de la capital
y los ucranianos están defendiendo
nuestros hogares con la voluntad y la fe
estamos en el terreno y nos estamos
defendiendo
si hemos recibido ayuda humanitaria
hemos recibido equipamiento militar
pero nunca es suficiente no es
suficiente
definitivamente debemos actuar juntos
porque estamos protegiendo nuestra
libertad
nuestra decisión y nuestros valores
democráticos del mundo occidental
definitivamente necesitamos el apoyo y
el aislamiento económico de rusia
porque cada dólar cada euro
cualquier divisa que entra al
presupuesto ruso será usada en armas
para matar a los ucranianos
yo sí
vitaly no ha habido una decisión por
parte de los países occidentales para
establecer una zona de exclusión aérea
incluso darle aviones a ucrania parece
ser un problema
de mx y esto no ocurre habrá bombardeos
aéreos en kiev en las próximas horas o
días es este su mayor temor
de agua
el mensaje para todo el mundo es que no
solo estamos luchando por ucrania no
solo estamos defendiendo nuestras casas
y nuestras familias en este momento el
peligro es para todo el mundo en europa
esta guerra afecta a todo el mundo
millones de personas ya se han mudado y
han encontrado lugares seguros
en occidente
ya han muerto miles de personas en este
momento estamos luchando estamos listos
para defender nuestro país
pero necesitamos ayuda porque estamos
luchando exactamente por los mismos
valores democráticos exactamente por los
mismos principios que hay en europa
todo el mundo debe entender que la razón
de esta guerra es porque ucrania decidió
ser parte de la familia europea
y los rusos quieren reconstruir el
imperio ruso y no aceptan nuestros
planes quieren llevar a cabo la idea de
reconstruir la unión soviética
nosotros fuimos parte de la urss y no
queremos volver a estar en la unión
soviética
por eso en este momento necesitamos
ayuda necesitamos más equipamiento
militar porque nos enfrentamos a uno de
los ejércitos más fuertes del mundo
al ejército ruso pero los soldados
ucranianos han hecho un gran trabajo han
destruido todos los planes
no es un secreto los rusos tenían
planeado tomarse que en los próximos
días
y ya
qué sientes vicky
nuestros soldados destruyeron esos
planes estamos listos para defender
nuestro país y defender nuestra ciudad
defender a nuestras familias defender
los mismos principios que ustedes
también tienen necesitamos apoyo militar
vitaly si usted hace parte de la defensa
territorial ha participado en combates
alrededor de kiev
y en este momento soy responsable del
servicio de calefacción electricidad
agua gas y de brindar ese servicio a las
personas
pero estoy con todos los combatientes y
si me necesitan tomaré las armas y
defenderé a nuestras familias defender
en nuestro país
cuántas personas se han ido de la
capital había 35 millones antes de la
guerra
en este momento mujeres y niños se han
ido de la capital y se quedaron los
hombres
y estimamos que unos dos millones de
personas se han quedado en que aquí
y que ver a una de las ciudades más
grandes de europa del este en este
momento estamos construyendo cuatro
puestos de avanzada desde quiere
puedo prometerle a todo el mundo que
nunca nos rendiremos lucharemos y nunca
le entregaremos nuestra ciudad a los
rusos
vladimir si tuviera enfrente a vladimir
putin que le diría
no he sido solo yo presidente macrón ha
hablado con él varias veces
no es posible entender una mente enferma
vladimir putin no vive en el mundo real
y una persona real sana nunca habría
hecho lo que la rusia de putin está
haciendo en ucrania matando inocentes
con creo que las conversaciones no
llevarán a ninguna parte no hay mucho
que decir las acciones hablan más que
las palabras
el ejército ruso está matando civiles
esas son las acciones esa es la imagen
del ejército ruso y del presidente putin
como conclusión para ambos se quedarán
en kiev sin importar lo que pase
winston que si
nos quedaremos en que los ciudadanos de
que me dieron el derecho de defender la
ciudad defender los intereses de la
población en nuestra capital y por eso
nos vamos a quedar en quiebra
defenderemos a nuestros ciudadanos
defenderemos nuestra ciudad y
defenderemos nuestro país
debo decir que estoy muy orgulloso de
nuestras mujeres y en particular que las
mujeres algunas se fueron con los niños
y otras dejaron a los niños en occidente
regresaron y están en el ejército
en la defensa territorial
defendiendo nuestro país
mujeres y hombres estoy orgulloso de
nuestros compatriotas ucranianos y estoy
orgulloso de ser ucranianos
yo me muevo por la ciudad voy a los
puestos de bloqueo y veo a las personas
que están ahí y
civiles que nunca habían pensado en
tomar las armas llevar han cambiado
tienen uniformes militares tienen armas
en sus manos
y otros muchísimos
actos de doctores músicos actores son
profesiones pacíficas pero ahora no
tienen otra opción deben defender a
nuestros niños ya nuestras familias
vitali y wladimir klitschko muchas
gracias por dedicarnos un poco de su
valioso tiempo en estas circunstancias
tan difíciles y por hablar con france24
desde kiev la capital de ucrania muchas
gracias
ones molt més i stay with us
y un mensaje corto quédense con nosotros
unidad unidad con principios con valores
esa es nuestra clave para ganar
quédense con ucrania no solo estamos
luchando por ucrania estamos luchando
por todo el mundo en europa es muy
importante la unidad es la clave para la
libertad muchas gracias por apoyar a
nuestro país los queremos a todos por su
apoyo gracias
muchas gracias de nuevo y gracias a
ustedes por acompañarnos en esta edición
especial de la entrevista aquí en france
[Música]